jerome powell the honorable central
banker was asked recently
do you believe that inflation was caused
by the russia invasion of ukraine and he
to his credit said no inflation was
already pretty high before russia
invaded ukraine and then the politician
who asked him said well why the hell is
the president keep saying that russia's
invasion of ukraine is leading to
inflation
is this an important kind of data point
in that now that central bankers not
only are they saying it's not transitory
but they're being
honest is like kind of a weird word but
they're at least being more transparent
about what they really think are the
drivers of inflation and they're not
just going with the talking points of uh
any one political party
yeah 100 man so i i feel bad for jerome
powell really any fair chair that has to
sit in front of our dysfunctional
congress and listen to what i believe
are the dumbest series of questions out
there i mean by joe but anyway so yeah
this whole inflation what's causing
inflation it's very clearly a political
football in dc and the reason that's a
political football is because we're
heading into a midterm elections where
i'm pretty sure the democrats are very
clearly going to get smoked uh as a
function of the the inflation the stock
market crash et cetera et cetera that's
a perfect recipe for for losing uh the
majority in the house and senate um with
respect to powell and this inflation
narrative he is being accurate and this
is something we've been talking about on
your program all year which is the
broadening out of inflation pressure you
know there's a couple statistics i'll
throw at the audience which is uh the
median cpi the federal reserve bank of
cleveland conti maintains a statistic uh
that shows the median price change
across all the different hundreds of
items in the cbi basket and on a median
basis it's up 6.4 on a three-month
annualized rate of change uh basis which
is the fastest rate of all time in the
time series going back to the early 80s
so we do have a problem with inflation
and it's broadening out and then with
respect to this whole russia ukraine
nonsense and let's put this to bed or at
least put it to bed for it was from the
pledge of our audience inflation was at
7.5 percent in january of 2022 before
russia crossed the border and set foot
into ukraine two when you look at what's
actually driving inflation now at this
particular juncture it's now services
inflation core services inflation at
seven point eight percent on a
three-month annualized basis that's the
fastest number we've seen since uh the
mid-90s or starting not the mid 90s the
middle of 1990 and so clearly it's you
know these are things that have very
little to do with you know rising food
and energy prices if you talk about you
know the the how much it costs to rent
your home or or get on an airplane or go
over in the hotel room
so
another component of this is that he was
asked do you believe that the united
states is potentially headed towards a
recession
and he basically said yes
which goes
directly against the white house press
secretary saying they do not see a
recession being imminent uh janet yellen
saying she does not see a recession
imminent
and it feels to a degree
that jerome powell is kind of breaking
ranks he's being a little bit more
honest a little bit more uh rational
intellectually uh humble even maybe to
some degree
how do you start to analyze if a central
banker is doing that is he signaling
that it may be way worse than people are
thinking it could get or is he just
trying to keep his own personal
credibility so that when he leaves as
the federal reserve chairman uh he's got
other opportunities you know from his
kind of professional career
no a great question man and there's a
couple things i'll unpack towards the
end of this but the one thing i will say
is that he's actually not breaking ranks
don't forget uh i'm going to say last
month
he treasury secretary janet yellen and
president biden huddled up together in
the oval office to decide what would be
the the sort of plan to tackle inflation
and more importantly i'm assuming what
was also going to be their communication
strategy and clearly the communication
strategy is from yellen's perspective
hey we got this wrong we're doing
something about it from president
biden's perspective it's all vladimir
putin and the fed's got to do something
about it and jay powell is willingly um
understanding that he's got the full
weight of the the credibility of the
federal reserve institution behind him
is effectively taking responsibility um
being sort of the scapegoat and
ultimately having to be the bad cop as
it relates to getting inflation under
control
i sent you a chart it might be a little
bit too wonky for this program but i
tend to think that everyone has the
ability to to learn and grow so uh can
you throw up that chart um
powell's still fighting to maintain
control over the bond market uh do you
have that one yeah the last one you sent
us yeah how old is fighting to maintain
control over the bond market what is
this showing us yeah so the second panel
the the bottom chart is the more
relevant one for this discussion which
shows the term premium uh in treasury
bonds so that's a very wonky specific
statistic but in layman's terms what it
means is how much sort of extra yield do
bond investors need to get compensated
for to take the risk of just owning a
bond because there's all sorts of
different uh volatility with growth
expectations different volatility with
inflation expectations policy rate
expectations et cetera et cetera and
right now that term premium is a minus
six basis points um you go back to the
last time we had the fed lose its
credibility in the you know mid to late
70s all the way into the early 80s until
paul berger started to get it back
you saw that statistic go all the way up
you know four or 500 basis points and so
right now what this is telling you is
that the bond market still believes the
fed is going to do something significant
to get inflation under control which is
why powell feels comfortable being the
bad cop uh it'll be a lot more difficult
for him to be the bad cop if we were
much higher levels on this chart i mean
at minus six basis points that's an
eighth percentile reading since going
back to the late 1950s so he's got a
decent amount of credibility he's got a
window to use it now if this window
closes and we don't get inflation under
control before the economy slows down
significantly then he's going to start
losing a significant amount of
credibility and that could be all hell
could be breaking loose in the bond
market so if we go and we take a look at
the the topping process uh you said
topping process is market
in-market-based inflation expectations
uh help people understand what a topping
process is and then how that relates to
these inflation expectations yeah great
question pop so so
topping processes so tops are generally
processes right like if you think about
like look at a chart of a stock they
should look at the chart of bitcoin
right uh you know actually bitcoin tends
to have these blow off top so eventually
mature as an asset class but you look at
the chart of the stock market as an
instance you know they tend to sort of
crest into the peak and when you look at
market internals you tend to sort of
lose leadership along the way into the
peak and it's usually sort of very
observed very measured process whereas
bottoms are usually catalyzed by some
sort of cathartic event and eventually
some sort of you know very aggressive
policy response to get you going in the
other direction uh so what i'm showing
in this chart here uh two year five year
10 year and 30-year inflation swap rate
this is what the market the bond market
is betting inflation is going to be
over the average of those durations and
so that the clearly the bond market is
saying hey look we are no longer
comfortable pricing inflation
expectations up and to the right off the
top of the chart anymore clearly
inflation on a reported basis is up and
to the right off the top of the chart
but the four looking you know sort of
martin going back to our discussion on
how markets for looking the bond market
is starting to say hey i think we're
starting to peak out in inflation
expectations terms which takes me to you
know sort of this next part of the
discussion which you were talking about
prior to me joining the program which is
this eventual transition to deflation
deflation going back to uh you know the
you know been the program for a while
now but for those of you who are new you
know we run a sophisticated sort of
systematic regime segmentation process
at 42 macro to help investors manage
macro risk and and one of those regimes
is called deflation that's where both
growth and inflation are slowing it
simultaneously you know that's you know
generally speaking it's a lot of what
you've seen on your screens year to date
uh could be a little bit worse for
certain asset classes um but also a
little bit better if you think you know
think about bonds you know potentially
starting to rally uh but very bad for
things like physical commodities et
cetera and digital commodities et cetera
and so maybe this is a leading indicator
of that sort of eventual transition to
deflation which we must we must go to we
must go through in order to get to the
good stuff get back to the good times